Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.
How are you guys doing? And welcome to
another video. We'll be deciphering the
Epstein files, some of the most
disturbing files that have been revealed
in modern times about how the elites are
operating. Uh the elites are operating.
And it's interesting, we've mentioned
many times that you don't find many
conservative Muslims in there except
people who are not conservative but
maybe uh Muslim by name. And one of the
things that have raised many eyebrows uh
actually has been the sending of aliswah
or a part of the kiswah which is the
cloth the ka uh to Jeffrey Epstein and
where in the email communications he's
mentioning that he wants pieces of the
cabba or at least that's being mentioned
to him. Um and we know that he's got
this temple that he had on the island
that had a dome like a masid on it. So
the question uh raises itself as to why
this is all the case and a plausible
explanation for this is that this is
used for sorcery and black magic. Now
many people will not understand what I
mean by that. Uh and especially if
you're coming from a secular or
materialist perspective. Uh black magic
and these kind of things are seen as
superstitions of old. But the truth of
the matter is black magic is clearly
something the elites understood and they
believed in. And the fact that pieces of
the Cabba or cloth of the Cabba or
something like that was sent is
something that was understood by Islamic
scholars a four time as well as by the
way Jewish scholars as well because the
desecration of sacred items or sacred
objects is some is a way is a method
that you can do black magic. And al-Qafi
mentions this for example I did a bit of
a search he mentions uh one of the
classical scholars of Islam that this is
a legitimate method of doing black magic
obviously black magic in Islamic
tradition is considered one of the major
sins that takes someone outside of the
pale of Islam because we worship in one
god alone and we don't worship in the
polytheistic
uh satans that these individuals worship
and this guy himself Epstein he probably
was Satan one of the satans one of the
jin One of one of the ins actually we
say inah
the last surah of the Quran the small
one of the smaller suras chapters of the
Quran
that there are
from the jin and from the n from the
human beings as well. So you can see
that this guy could have been a devil
and he's tampering and playing around
and playing around with the with the
sorcery. Yeah. and he needs these
objects in order to do it. And that's
why he's building a a temple-like
structure and asking for pieces of the
Ka. But it also demonstrates and
illustrates that they knew there was
something holy about Islam. That's why
would somebody who is not an enthusiast
about Islam, was not a Muslim. He didn't
seem interested in that stuff. Why would
he be asking why did he care about
having these sacred items? It doesn't
make any sense. And the most plausible
uh explanation and the best inference to
the best explanation is that he was
using it for sorcery and that they knew
deep down that this atheistic
materialistic worldview as we'll talk
about when we talk about the new atheist
movement and how he shunned them
completely. This guy he shunned them.
Yeah. he wasn't impressed with this guys
that he was a superstitious man and that
the elites are superstitious people and
they understood that there are spirits
and that there are uh there's another
realm out there and so that's the first
thing I'll mention the second thing I'll
mention is that you've got another
individual here whose name is Hind Elise
who recently come out she's a proud
feminist she is actually I call her a
pseudo Islamic feminist and this is a
movement that I'm going to be hither to
hence Fourth be coining yeah the piffs
the pseudoislamic feminists people who
pretend to be uh adherence of Islamic
religion and tenants but compromise
those tenants or reject them in order to
uh appease a feministic worldview. She's
clearly one of them. As you can see in
the next clip here she's talking about
women's rights. Let's take a look at
that clip. But really to build the case
that investing in women is not just the
right thing to do, but it's also the
smart thing to do.
>> Yeah, she's talking about women's
rights, but then we find that she has uh
no less than how many mentions? Uh 469
469 mentions in the Epstein files. And
there's there's even one of those
mentions where she's saying that in one
of the emails to Mr. Epstein that if you
thought I was pretty which is I don't
know if he maybe he told her that maybe
she told and he was trying to chirp so I
was trying to give her a couple good
words here and there you know this maybe
this Mr. Epstein and she was liking that
he then she starts offering h
or sorry it's her sister. Yeah. She's
saying my sister's even prettier. So
what's what's that? So if you thought I
was pretty huh then what about my
sister? You maybe and they infer some of
the people online they're saying that
she was 13 years old. We don't know
exactly how old she was. But the point
is this is that you can see that these
elites
these elites altogether they are
dabbling they are dabbling with very
penicious and disgusting uh themes and
bal this which this false god that's
mentioned in the Quran that some of the
ancient Levventine people maybe the
Canaanite and so on is mentioned in the
Old Testament as well is mentioned in
the Quran
a Jew call
and leave the best of creators. Allah
mentions him in the Quran that now
they're saying that was the name of the
it was meant to be bank and it's all
mixed up and whatever. No, I don't think
so. I think that they were worshiping
this Bal and I believe that they are com
doing this uh sacrifices. Bal himself is
linked by the way if you do a bit of
research you'll find to child sacrifice.
This is a very creepy elitist thing.
There's lots of lessons from this.
Number one, the elites in the world do
not believe
in the materialistic worldview. They are
superstitious people and they do believe
in the holiness of Islam. It doesn't
make any sense not to believe in the
holiness of Islam but call for one of
the uh the pieces of the Kaa to be sent.
If I'm a if I don't believe in the
holiness of Hinduism or seekism, but
then go and and uh try start dealing
with the the GGS or whatever the Bagad
Gita in a manner that I believe is holy,
then it contradicts my claim that I
don't believe it's holy at all. That's
number one. So they believe in something
to do with the holiness of Islam. So
it's kind of an internal admission.
Number two, he wasn't impressed, as
we'll come to talk about in more detail,
with the new atheist movement and then
and the elites themselves don't seem to
be materialists in that way. Number
three, they were building temples and
even they in their hedonistic pursuits
couldn't escape some kind of a
polytheistic worship. Number four, that
people at that level, okay, even this
Hindu Eloise who's who's fratonizing
with Mr. uh Epstein, she's meant to be a
Muslim person, but she's a piff pseudo
Islamic feminist type three, which will
come to the type. So, I'm going to make
a whole presentation about feminism
soon, which will be out on this channel
about pseudo Islamic feminism in
particular. There's going to be an
entire presentation with breaking uh or
cutting edge material that's going to
come here that she was uh involving her
sister in this manner and this this that
and the other. And there is this
disgusting double standard uh relating
to these people. And actually if someone
identifies with a western ideology and
claims to be Muslim that is a good sign
that they are that they are somebody is
so I'm not saying this particular
individuals you you don't even know her
situation. And by the way a lot of
people have been talking about the UAE
and people in the UAE and there's lots
of UAE people in this list and so on.
But I tell you I have had interactions
with people from the UAE from the
Emirates. Some of them are very good
people. Some of them I have uh had
excellent relations with and some of
them are very bad people of course and
that's what mal does money if people
are given money uh as a fitna it
destroys sometimes their spirituality uh
and that doesn't matter if you're from
the UAE or from the Saudi Arabia or from
any other country actually there is a
strong positive correlation between
corruption of the soul and money okay
and that's why Allah he keeps talking
about
that certainly your children and your
monies is a fitna which shows you that
when you get to a certain level that you
have to now have and you have to have
caution with yourself and your
spirituality. Okay. And it also gives us
the wisdom as to why Allah has not
allowed every single Muslim nation to be
a very rich nation. Because if all of
the Muslim nations were rich nations,
we'd have more fitna and more apostasy
and more and more of this stuff. And
it's better to be poor and spiritual
than rich and af hypocrite, a religious
hypocrite. So there's lots of lessons to
be learned here. Uh but the point is
that these elites are unsatisfied and
they're actually insatiable.
The elites are insatiable. What does it
take to get to a level where you need
that kind of sexual excitement in order
to be uh sustained? Like, you know, you
start low maybe and then you keep going
this and that and then you go for the
kids and then you go for that and the
sacrifices and and then the how many
BDSM things have we seen on this thing
and the torturing and the choking and
this and that
and the code words for all of the
because what they've done is they've
raised the bar okay so much yeah that
these elites they need so much uh
stimulation in order to uh get off now
in order to enjoy them time they cannot
do it through the conventional route.
which shows you the disenchantment of
sex and the demystification of it and
the accessibility
of it actually has the adverse effect
when you're interested in hedonistic
pursuits so much and you're and you find
it so accessible that actually
becomes harder to please you from from
that perspective the conservative
Islamic position which is that you have
discipline self-discipline religious
discipline at tawa and so on and so
forth actually makes you enjoy those
things like sexual intercourse etc more
than a hedenist would because the
hedenist is no longer the guy for
example Epstein had erectile dysfunction
he had erectile dysfunction and there's
some letters saying that he needed to
increase his the size of his penis and
all of these kinds of things
I don't you know this is this is the
situation of these elites they're
insatiable they're unsatisfied they're
unhappy they're doing magic
Yeah, they still believe but they
believe in the false gods. They've sold
their soul and believe you me, this is
not this is just the tip of the iceberg
what you're seeing here.
But they couldn't get to the
conservative Muslims. You won't find the
true believer on that list on the
Epstein list because
to be honest with you, a true believer
is the one that despite everything, no
money, no woman, no
whatever it is he was offering, he was
offering lots of things to lots of
people was going to face them and that's
what inshallah we hope to have his and
steadfastness of the religion of Islam
and with that we'll conclude
>> your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a masjid, a
daer center. This center, this masid,
this educational institution will act
like a beacon of light, calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam. So give generously and Allahel
will give you even more.